だーっ
こんにちははじめせそうですということ私
はじめ3冊をこのチャンネルを始めて約9
年9年近く経っているわけなんですけれど
さん寝るのアイコンってあるじゃないです
か僕といえばスライムみたいなイメージが
あるかなぁ今もあるかわかんないんです
けど昔スライムで一時代を風靡スター男
みたいな印象あると思いがちなんですけど
もな声と言いますが別に帰るよでもないし
このままでいい c いい感じだなと思っ
てずっと僕のチャンネルのアイコンがこれ
なんですよ黄緑色のスライム風呂に
飛び込んでる肇社長っていうチャンネル
アイコンこのイメージが強すぎて帰りよう
にも変えられないな2回目のこれより上に
行くのかこんな素敵なアイコンより良い
ものが撮れるかと言われると中ならないと
思うんですよスライムってそれはもう綺麗
だし行き塗りの前身包んでこんなポーズで
最高の刺しこれを上回るアイコンなんて
なかなかできないと思うので約6年間回ず
にここまできました今までありがとう
ございました教会ます今日買えま a
もちろん変えましたも
ただた今潜ったとおりこの美しい完璧な
王妃もスライム黒外交を超えるのは難しい
と思ったのでちょっとだけのマイナー
チェンジしようかなと思っておりますと
いうより今日の動画肇社長のチャンネル
アイコンがスライムプロからただの風呂に
代わっていたら気づく気付かない良い
欠航が混ぜていただきましたいいのが
思いついたらそれが買えますけども幻聴
これを超え以降飾り社長感を出すのは
ムーディーだなと思って出ればわずかな
マイナーチェンジをしてみようかなと思っ
て気付くか気付かれないかくらいの微妙な
変化今回ですねまずは the 黄緑色い
を振るを準備して2015年か2016年
ぐらいに撮影した当時の5年前が抜け年前
の擦れるぶりに飛び込んでたバック聞こえ
の肇社長のポージングカメラの位置
アングルすべても完全再現しようと頑張っ
て頑張って模索して模索してカメラも盗作
して模索してこんな感じ取り組んだ
ben
あああああ要素がもう
高校
[音楽]
6回ぞああああああああああああっ
ていろいろいい
ええええええ
ん
今の僕のチャンネルのアイコンがこちら
ですねうーん確かに若干は回かな北一重
だったんですよ昔提携してないんですけど
なんか歳を重ねるんですけど瞼が重くなっ
てきて負担になっていて当然一重だしなん
か目がちょっと細いような気もしますね
これが今のアイコンなんですけどもこれを
韓国しようとしライムブルーではなくただ
の風呂で弾い鳥色のターン風呂でコピー
完全コピーした傘寿こちらでどうぞ
[音楽]
これ結構
大変でしたよどうですかこの手の角度つけ
ている腕時計
シュノーケルの一応の傾きの角度が若干
完全とはいかないんですけども
youtube のチャンネル内コーナー
でそんな近いもんでもないからなんとなく
多分大丈夫かなぁとってくれたんですほぼ
ねほぼ同じ角度でできたんじゃないかなと
思っています
その傾きとかまずで装備つをフェイスで1
時間近く俺を黒でこういうことをずっと
やってましたからねし使った使ったけど
やっぱりこれをもとに作るしかないかなと
思ってライブ者にて伸び4からないぐらい
の違いだと思ってるんですよあとは
顔がちょっぴり落ち着いた若い頃と比べて
顔が落ち着いたね俺も僕そんな変わって
ないと思って火を使うという感じでですね
えと今のアイコンとこれから帰るアイコン
でございますさあ視聴者さんの皆さんこの
わずかな変化に気づくことができるん
でしょただいまの時刻16時17君も夕方
前で学生3を変えるかな帰らないかな
ぐらいと使ってるんですけども今から
チャンネルのアイコンを変えます
短足変えていきましょうこれが今の僕の
チャンネルですねアイコンがこれです
やっぱりちょっと小さいですよねこれぞ
フィール c の編集押せばおっ
うわ緊張するなみんな気づいてくれるか
なぁ代えさせていただきます
6年の歴史に
一つの変化をつけていきますよいきます
チェーンジ
実は
ダメさん似てるなあこれ多分魔女わかん
ないと思うんだよなはい
バーガー
ありますいるよちょっと5変わりますね
変わりました皆さん今肇社長の約6年間
使ったと思われるチャンネルアイコンが
変わりましたそうするかうん彼のもう
変わっているちょっと手前儲かってます
あとはこれファンの方が気づくかどうか
ですねさああとはツイッターでファンの皆
さんが気づいてくれるか動画です一番最初
に気付いたファンの方にはは40億円を
上げますん
今宵
あっは
[音楽]
blare んっ
横井
ちょっん
おっしゃっちょマーグ待って早すぎん
まっでもサザナーラ早瀬キビやばいいんだ
けど一瞬だったしてやりがとーそんな早く
気づくことある全く告知も何もしないのに
耐えて1分以内で分かったんで本当に
すごい方でしたっでも他の人気づくかなぁ
を2つまでしか削れん続いてない気がする
んだけどねこれさもこの人やばいよと口座
を持ったり雪ん子損を築いたね素晴らしい
この変化に気づけるのは本当にすごいよや
すごいマジで感動しましたよく気づく猫の
変化に
じゃあなんかかあ
ピントこんな
おとそ